oh hi river babes welcome back to
Sweetwater secrets I'm your host Liana
Galera although today I'm feeling a lot
more like a blossom and this is your
preview episode 4 to 13 chapter 26 the
tell-tale heart where we can freak out
over where we left off and what lies
ahead now we have so much to discuss
today you guys have submitted so many
awesome comments about your top
riverdale theories and thoughts so thank
you so much for being so engaged and
active in the comments and chatting with
me on Twitter kisses to you and to thank
you I've got a little present coming
your way today I have exclusive answers
from Riverdale showrunner Roberto
aguirre-sacasa about the most mysterious
character lurking around town and you'll
never guess who I'm talking about so get
excited but first let's take a look at
your talk kisses and kisses from chapter
25 the wicked and the divine all right
guys now kicking things off Miranda
Joyce commented kisses to land for being
super honest and for sharing your
criticisms as well as your favorite
things about the show I like that it's
not just biased or a promo for the show
oh thank you so much Miranda you know
I'm a fan just like you guys but I'm
also a journalist who can get you guys
some answers so I'll have a lot more on
that in just a little bit stay tuned now
Miranda Joyce also added I'm Catholic
and I've never heard anyone singing at a
confirmation especially not walking down
the aisle or to a song from cruel
intentions lol now New Orlean Magro
agreed that Veronica's musical moment at
her confirmation was not normal saying I
was cringing so hard but I loved the
song she also said and I loved the fact
that Betty lied so bighead will break up
again hashtag team barchi now Madison
Scott also had similar thoughts saying
guys I have a feeling that bug head
isn't gonna last
due to Betty lying to Jughead about that
kiss with Archie sorry but Jughead
deserves better
while some fans were not feeling the
bug-head love plenty of others were so
excited that Betty and Jughead took the
next step in their relationship now any
Owens couldn't get enough saying kisses
to bug head before this F I didn't ship
bug head but now I love them but hisses
to not seeing much of Kevin and Sheryl
town is seriously oh now as for that
dark Betty on the webcam scene yeah
Haley K said hisses hisses hisses I
cannot give enough hisses to how mental
health is being treated right now mental
health is not a plot device nor should
it be sexualized I'm sorry
I love Riverdale but I loathe the dark
Betty
plot agreed wholeheartedly Haley
meanwhile musically nerdy also had some
questions writing is BAE and honorary
serpent do you think that she'll follow
in her mother's footsteps and become an
official serpent you know Alice was
surprisingly controlled and not freaking
out when she was cleaning up the blood
so I guess serpents don't shed their
skin easily and speaking of skins Julie
Grace commented I love your jacket can I
borrow it sometime oh you must mean my
Riverdale varsity jacket that I wore it
last week now you guys I love that one
and if you're following me on Twitter
and Instagram you'll see that I always
show off all my Riverdale swag and where
you can find your own so keep an eye out
for that and our last comment of the
week comes from Brooke saloon and she
wrote hey isn't the boy Ben that came to
see chick miss Grundy's boyfriend in
episode 1 season 2 oh my goodness Brooke
this is my favorite observation yet and
we have a lot to discuss so here we go
all right guys now at first I literally
just thought that all random extras in
Riverdale looked alike but yes that Ben
who was apparently interviewing chick
for a job at the Bijou is this same boy
who's smooching on grundy just moments
before she was viciously murdered by the
black hood but are you really ready for
something that's going to blow your
minds that was not the first time that
we met Ben now way back in season 1
episode 4 to be exact
beggar was working at the concession
stand at the Twilight drivin
when Kevin decided to drown his romance
sorrows and junk food in a hotdog Who am
I trying to raise where are the dogs so
this leads us to a brand new
investigative segment that I'm making up
right now called who the hell are you
hot dog dude now listen closely river
babes because if you're like me then
you're wondering right now who is Ben
and why does he keep popping up all over
Riverdale at the most random and
sometimes shadiest moments but I'm not
just here to theorize with my fellow
Riverdale fans now here on Sweetwater
secrets I'm all about getting you
answers so I channeled my inner Betty
Cooper and sat down with Riverdale's
executive producer Roberto
aguirre-sacasa at a screening this week
and asked him to give me the exclusive
scoop on this mysterious reappearing
character who could this mystery baby
Roberto told me quote I can tell you
that he is going to continue popping up
we feel like every time he pops up he's
an Easter Egg for people because some
people notice him and some people don't
and there is a resonance as to why he
keeps popping up but stay tuned
there will be more sightings and when I
pressed Roberto and asked is been
popping up for a reason he told me quote
yes for sure now I can tell you that
Beng will not be appearing in chapter 28
the tell-tale heart but I can tell you
that everything is about to get really
really juicy especially in the Cooper
household also here's something else
that you guys should know before tuning
in to episode 213 the tell-tale heart
was directed by Julie Plec who you would
know best as the executive producer of
The Vampire Diaries and the originals
now Julie does a phenomenal job of
tackling the new are themes of this
episode especially one key bug-head
scene so get excited for that alright
guys now that does it for this week's
preview episode of Sweetwater secrets
check back with me after you watch
episode 213 chapter 26 the telltale
heart for answers on the episodes most
shocking moment now in the meantime hit
the Kaunas and tell me your thoughts
what do you think Ben is really up to
what are your biggest
Riverdale theories at this point go
ahead and tell them to me and then give
this video a like and hit subscribe on e
t--'s youtube channel so you never miss
an episode of Sweetwater secrets Tata
for now river babes
[Music]